here's what would happen if we dug
tunnels between continents avoiding all
the water and digging through the ground
from England all the way to America
would take an incredibly long time
instead you could make one massively
long 5500 kilometer tube and place it
over the ocean then using anchors you
drag the tube down about 45 meters and
secure the tube using wires tied to the
ocean's floor to travel through your
tube quickly you'd need to use vac
trains this system would essentially act
as a vacuum that would take out all the
air from the tube this will allow a
train to travel at incredibly high
speeds due to there being little to no
air resistance not only that but our
train would also be levitating using
high-powered magnets you'd be going
about 2 000 kilometers an hour which is
almost double the speed of sound so